you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dresses of course
it's coming from a guy that wears a
toilet seat on his head we don't leave
one of our own behind hopefully harley's
still alive no funny business colonel
these are dangerous people team two is
clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you were here to save you you were
gonna save me it was a really good plan
too well i can go back inside and you
can still do it that's patronizing i'm
so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all going to die i hope so
oh for [__] sake here's the deal
we fail a mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early
although that isn't an open invitation
for you to cough without covering your
mouth
what's the pleasure how much to know
you're the leader you're supposed to be
decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans who knows why
mad men do what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
i'm going to get you out of here alive
oh my god we've got to freaking kaiju up
in this [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love the rain like angels are
splooting all
over us
you